-Our next guest hosts the new
series "B.S. The Game Show,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
He also returns as a judge
on the new season of
"America's Got Talent," which
premieres May 31st at 8:00 p.m.
right here on NBC.
Please welcome Howie Mandel!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Howie Mandel. That's what I'm
talking about. Wow.
-My God.
Wow. What a day.
-Oh, my God.
-I got to just say.
I got here early.
And I got to meet Post Malone.
He has been such
an influence on me.
[ Laughter ]
And just to spend quality time
with that guy, oh, my gosh.
-You're a big fan?
-Oh, I am. You have no idea.
-No, we have an idea.
I think we have an idea.
-No, you don't.
Post Malone means so much to me.
I adore him. And he is just --
People think, "How can he
influence you?"
And he does.
-He does.
It's good to find out.
You learn something new.
You look great.
How was the pandemic? Rough?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Yeah. I'll be honest with you.
I had COVID. I got COVID.
-I can't believe
that you got COVID.
-Because I go nowhere, I'm a
germophobe, but I won --
"A.G.T." won
the Kids' Choice Awards.
They made me go to
And a lot of people get slimed.
I went viral.
[ Laughter ]
-Literally, yeah.
-But I didn't feel -- I got
vaxxed and boosted, so I had
no -- The hardest thing for me
was to be locked in the room.
I was locked --
I was quarantined.
-Of course, you have to.
-Yeah. I was.
So I did the stick-and-poke, and
I figured that's what this is.
I did it to myself.
-You self-boostered.
-I self-boostered myself.
[ Laughter ]
You know what was weird, though?
My wife, who takes lovely care
of me -- I love her.
I've been married for 42 years.
Said, "You got to quarantine for
10 days."
So for 10 days,
locked in a room.
Nobody. Did nothing. By myself.
And then I got out, and I read
the CDC said five days.
My wife --
[ Laughter ]
It's not funny.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, alright, you're right.
-Not funny.
You know what I realized?
We've been married 42 years.
And I spent most of my life
on the road and traveling.
Up until COVID, I was doing
like 200 live dates a year.
So the thrill was
not having me there.
So the fact that I was there,
she imposed a quarantine.
Every day, I would get up,
and I was going crazy.
But she locked me in the room,
and I could open the door
and there was a little cookie.
I played hide-and-go-seek alone.
Alone.
[ Laughter ]
-That's exciting.
Did you ever find yourself?
-Not -- Once. Once.
And it's because I used
the same hiding place twice.
[ Laughter ]
But just alone in the room going
"Ollie Ollie home free."
-I want to ask about -- I know
you have so many things
going on, but one I really enjoy
is this podcast
that you kind of started with
your daughter.
-My daughter, Jacqueline Shultz.
I do a podcast -- because I was
locked in at the beginning of
the pandemic and she wouldn't
come see me because I'm old.
And she thinks that --
No, because you weren't allowed
to be around people over 60.
-That's correct.
-So she would phone me
and we would do prank calls.
And we would spend hours.
And we'd do challenges.
And I'd call my friends.
And my wife came in and said,
"Why are you doing this?"
And I go,
"Just because it's fun."
And she said, "Record it."
So that became my podcast.
"Howie Mandel Does Stuff,"
and it's with my daughter.
[ Audience aws ]
Aww. Aww.
[ Laughter ]
This week, you know, Bill Burr,
Jim Jeffries --
Everybody comes by and does it.
And it's just -- Will you do it?
-Of course, I'll do it.
Yeah, I would love to.
I'd do anything for
Howie Mandel.
-Really?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is so great.
-Let's go get a tattoo after the
show. We'll talk about it.
-I will gladly
stick and poke you.
-Ah, thank you.
-If you're just tuning in,
that doesn't sound right.
-Yeah, but we were talking
about it earlier.
Let's talk about
"America's Got Talent" first.
That's May 31st on NBC.
That's our big NBC show.
-And we're all back.
-Everyone is back?
-Everybody's back.
Simon is back.
Sofia is back. Heidi is back.
Terry Crews is back.
Simon is back on the bike,
which he shouldn't be.
-No.
-That was frightening enough.
-He's fallen off twice.
-Twice?
-Twice.
He broke his back.
He broke his arm.
He had a concussion,
and then he got engaged.
[ Laughter ]
-You think there's a c--
-No, I don't think there's
a connection.
He's registered at Target
if anybody wants to get them
something.
-Is he a Target guy?
-No, I was just joking.
-Oh good, yeah.
Let's talk about "B.S."
-Okay.
-It's streaming right now
on Netflix.
I can't say the actual title.
-No, you can't.
It's my favorite show
in the world.
It really is because they said,
"Do a trivia show."
I said, "I hate trivia.
I know nothing."
But the key is, you don't have
to know the answers.
You just have to be able to tell
if the person is lying.
If you can lie, if you can B.S.
and convince one person
the answer is right,
you still win the money.
We gave away millions of dollars
to idiots who knew nothing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, finally.
-That's on Netflix.
-Netflix said, "Yeah, perfect."
I like this idea for a show.
-It is.
-It's fun.
-Do you B.S.?
-I could play.
Yeah, I could do, yeah.
I could probably win
a lot of money.
-Really? I think the best things
I've gotten in life is
because I B.S.'d because I lied.
-Yeah, actually
I'm a terrible liar.
-Are you?
-I'm really bad.
-I'm so good at lying.
-But I'm good at trivia, so I
might be good at this game.
-The trivia is real hard.
You don't watch the show
for trivia.
You watch the show to watch
their face like poker,
to say, "This person knows
nothing. This is bull."
And if you can call them out --
If everybody calls bull
on the person and there actually
is bull, then they're out.
But if they can convince one
person, they win the money.
-It's called
"B.S. The Game Show."
-I wrote it right here.
-Here is Howie Mandel.
[ Laughter ]
-I actually -- I took science,
and I...
And I -- [Bleep] Sorry.
[ Laughs ] Um...
[ Laughs ]
Um...
No, the answer's bomboloni.
Sorry.
I know that for a fact.
-And he took science.
-Yes, I took sci-- Well, yeah.
Bomboloni.
-He loves bomboloni,
and he took science.
[ Applause ]
Was he lying? Was he bull?
-That might be the worst liar.
-That was the worst.
-That was the worst liar.
-I don't mean to say -- We can't
even say the name of the show.
I'm not allowed to say it.
Right?
-You can say it.
We can't air it.
But sure, say it.
-You know what?
And they even changed the name.
It wasn't always called "B.S."
-What was it called?
-"This [Bleep] Show."
[ Laughter ]
Howie Mandel, everybody.
Check out "B.S." -- I'm happy
to do it with this one.
"B.S. The Game Show"
now on Netflix.